I was on my way home one evening quite
late at night on the bus so I wasn't
paying much attention to what was going
on around me until I suddenly looked
down and realized that the man sitting
next to me had his hand on my leg he
moved his hand upwards and grabbed me in
the crotch because I was on the phone to
my mum I said I'm on the bus this man
just groped me and everybody on the bus
heard me and everybody looked away
nobody stepped in no one challenged him
no one even made eye contact with me and
it sent me such a powerful message it
felt like they were saying we don't want
anything to do with this this is your
thing it made me feel that I was at
fault that I'd done something wrong I
felt incredibly embarrassed and ashamed
and confused and I got off the bus at
the next stop and walked the rest of the
way home
and looking back I wasn't the only
person who got such a powerful message
that night so did the man who groped me
he got the message you can get away with
this
it said the message that this was just
acceptable
you
we're so used to receiving the message
from all around us all the time that
women and girls are sexual objects that
our bodies are public property and that
we really are the sum of our individual
parts there are witchcraft cases from
Europe 400 years ago where for example a
woman was accused of witchcraft for
giving a man a permanent erection the
idea that men couldn't possibly be
expected to control themselves is
nothing new but it's also something
that's still really impacting people's
lives even today now were you able to
wear undergarments you're like the fifth
person that's because to ask somebody
what kind of Underpants they were I
didn't ask you what kind you just asked
me if I was wearing any could you know
what you where did you wear clothes wear
dungarees you can't wear clothes under
and it's like a it's like a wetsuit okay
practically so you answer my question
well I don't know maybe it's a little
bit more than wetsuit was I wearing
underwear I mean gosh
I think the defensive nurse here is
really key this idea that he is
immediately reaching so I haven't done
anything wrong you're overreacting and
they kind of gets a little bit of
support from that from her male co-star
and this is something that we see a lot
of that if women try to challenge this
kind of thing tried to speak out often
there can be a closing of ranks and a
sense of you don't get to be upset about
this in most British homes parents
clearly differentiate between their sons
and daughters but not in this North
London household here they aim to bring
up their children in what they call a
non sexist way I think what's really sad
watching this now is that it still feels
a little bit revolutionary
[Music]
[Music]
she makes it sound so simple doesn't she
how is it possible that this child gets
it and yet every time a large retailer
agrees to stop gendering its toys or its
or its children's clothes as for boys or
for girls you'll see a backlash in the
press these kinds of stereotypes that
are so insidious and so low-level
they're so often dismissed is not a big
deal in reality all we're saying is that
kids should have the choice that just as
she says you know some girls might like
princesses and some might like
superheroes but shouldn't they have the
option the reality is that fewer than
one in ten of our engineers is female
our royal society one of our biggest
scientific institutions has never had a
female president so no of course these
things aren't the end of the world on
their own but do they contribute to a
world in which girls are very very
gently and slowly told this isn't for
you this isn't for you of course they do
and actually the end of the effect is
quite extreme Andy Sam is the first u.s.
player to reach a major semi-final since
2009 how would you describe a male
player we are seeing an increasing
number of male role models who are
choosing to step in and just to mention
this stuff when it happens not
necessarily in a particularly aggressive
or
angry way but but simply just mentioning
it so that that isn't allowed to stand
if you haven't experienced sexism
yourself like with other forms of
prejudice it becomes much easier to
ignore and to deny the reality of its
existence it's easy to suggest that
people are overreacting that they must
be making something up because you
haven't seen it essentially the truth is
that we can't change this as long as
everybody just thinks it's normal
you